President Vladimir zielenski and prime
minister Georgia Maloney greeted each
other like old friends it's the first
time since Ukraine's president has
visited Italy since Russia invaded his
country last year
but the two met in February when Maloney
traveled to Kiev to assure him of
Italy's continued support she insists
this hasn't wavered Italian
Italy proved with its actions its full
support for the sovereignty and
territorial Integrity of Ukraine which
is the victim of an unjust and brutal
aggression by the Russian Federation and
this is what Italy intends to continue
to do
on behalf of all ukrainians I'm grateful
to all Italians whose Hearts do not
remain indifferent to evil and who
support us with Aid in defense
then it was off to the Vatican to meet
Pope Francis who's been working on a
peace Plan before zelenski a
satisfactory piece requires Ukraine's
much anticipated spring offensive be
successful and for that he needs to keep
the flow of weapons and money from
allies open
on Saturday Germany unveiled its biggest
military aid package of the war so far
three billion dollars worth of armored
vehicles artillery anti-aircraft systems
and drones and the EU has pledged that
member states will speed up ammunition
supplies
in the bang mood area where fighting
continues
Ukraine needs about 1 000 shops of
artillery per day
one thousand per day just in Bangalore
in order to have an idea or the
intensity of the fighting
on the front lines early signs of
Ukraine's offensive are taking shape
though this footage isn't independently
verified Ukraine's third assault Brigade
says it's them pushing back Russian
forces flanking the embattled city of
bakmut
Ukraine has also been showing new deeper
strike capabilities this is the
aftermath of an attack in
russian-occupied lugansk Russia says
Ukraine used two Storm Shadow cruise
missiles which the UK recently announced
its applied Kiev
adding to Russia's sense of unease that
momentum is swinging against them
several Russian aircraft came down in
what should be safe territory as many as
two military helicopters and two jet
fighters were destroyed across the
Russian Border in briansk
whether by friendly fire or Ukrainian
attack it's more bad news for Russia's
military and good news for the Ukrainian
forces set on winning back their land
Rory challenge Al Jazeera